turkish airstrikes and artillery
bombardment are targeting the defenses
of the kurdish LED syrian democratic
forces as the turkish army advances into
northeast Syria on some fronts Turkish
soldiers and their local allies the
opposition Syrian National Army pushed a
few kilometers deep capturing several
villages and mainly spacely populated
areas the SDF is outgunned and outmanned
by the second largest army in the NATO
alliance but Kurdish LED forces are
putting up resistance promising to make
any battle long and hard the flat
terrain however will make it difficult
to hold their ground in the face of
heavy firepower the immediate focus of
turkey's air and ground operation is a
100 kilometer stretch of territory from
the Syrian border town of Tel Aviv hind
me to the border town of raza Lane to
the east it is an area the US military
would drew from earlier this week it
seems the Turkish army and its local
allies want to secure rural areas before
moving into towns international aid
agencies are warning of an impending
humanitarian disaster they also warned
of mass displacement Turkish commanders
say civilians and civilian
infrastructure are not the targets of
the campaign thousands of Syrians are
already on the move fleeing hostilities
which are still largely confined to
border areas but the safe zone turkey
says it wants to create extends 480
kilometers along the border and 30
kilometers deep turkey says the
operation is about getting rid of a
security threat it considers the Syrian
Kurdish armed group the YPG which forms
the backbone of the SDF a terrorist
organization the Turks also want
millions of refugees it is looking after
to move to the safe zone for years
Syrians fled from Raqqa Deir Ezzor and
other areas they fled from ISIL and the
YPG Turkey's province of song loofah is
home to 400,000 Syria's and 125 thousand
of them live here and this Turkish
border town they need to be able to go
home
the Western Arab countries are not on
board with turkeys plan that some say
will create demographic changes
president Rajab type or the GaN hit back
we have three point six million Syrian
refugees in our country waiting to go
back to their homes the European Union
look at yourself
I repeat at the moment you cannot call
or define our operation as an invasion
our job is easy we could just open the
doors and 2.6 million refugees we will
send them back to you don't you sure
that it was sundown watch these young
Saudi Arabia should look in the mirror
they put Yemen in the situation and look
what's happening there tens of thousands
of people are dying in Yemen Saudi
Arabia you should talk about this first
you cannot criticize our operation also
Egypt you cannot talk at all
you're the murder of democracy in your
country leaders of turkeys government
and military commanders haven't spelled
out the scope of their campaign much may
depend on planned talks between Oregon
and US President Donald Trump next
months but the growing criticism of
turkeys actions in Syria is another
battle the government in Ankara is
facing sanika dar al jazeera on the
turkey-syria border